so at design singapore council we work
to talk
we use design-led thinking approaches to
address policy
and planning challenges and also to come
up with solutions for our users
our job is really to help singapore
designers to empower
to bridge cultures to design with the
impact
and also to help designers to respond to
global challenges
our role is to uplift businesses
and get them to adopt design and design
thinking in their organization
so at school of x we coach people
to learn how to solve problems to their
everyday issues they face at home
or in work i engaged senior management
and key decision makers in the
institutes of higher learning
industry as well as the government to
co-create solutions to address
manpower and educational challenges we
ran sessions to create
create awareness at the same time we
have support schemes for
businesses to adopt design the beautiful
thing about
designing singapore council is that you
know we are quite small and
we have so many things that we want to
achieve so many problems they want to
solve for so many people
it's a work environment where you'll be
inspired and also play an important role
to contribute to the development of the
creative culture in singapore
everyone here is given an area that they
need to
make change right to come up with better
programs
or policies right to support you know
the people that we are serving
if there's something i appreciate and
like about design thing for council
culture is um
it feels very inclusive we collaborate
together and really um
put in a lot of talk to really see how
we can help to grow the design sector in
singapore
i find that dsg
is a really safe space to fail
it's fine to try new things to find that
it doesn't work
right to fail in that sense but always
to be very supported
you're surrounded by people who have
your back you're surrounded by people
who are supportive
who includes you who doesn't make you
feel left out who looks out for you
the team here at the design singapore
council is really diverse we have design
and non-design colleagues working
together you're not doing the same thing
over and over again
you get to know and experience the
different aspects of design
yeah so it's not boring you know it's
fun always trying
new ways and just doing new things doing
10 different ways of trying to solve the
problem just
doing 20 different ways right i think
you will really find that
you have a different perspective of what
design is i think the people who should
join esg
uh people who are passionate about
design i think people who
want to make change a positive change
someone who's energized
antistick uh someone who has the passion
because i care to help as many people
understand that when they face problems
in their work life or at home
there is a way to find a solution to it
i believe design
exists to solve problems and so it can
be applied in
anything and everything actually when we
help designers
and when they win we win even if there's
a small league
it actually leads us to go further i can
actually create those opportunities for
people to experience
design for themselves in their everyday
lives it makes us understand that what
we are doing is
there's a sense of satisfaction so it's
a place where you can make impact
it's a place where you can be inspired
and it's a place where you can have fun
[Music]